what if I told you this was the last
Monday morning of your life what if I
told you you died this week would you
complain about your crap job or that
test you don't want to take I doubt it
if you're not pumped right now if you're
begrudging what you're about to do if
you're not looking forward to it look
we're living in a world where there's so
much more opportunity this internet
thing created way more opportunity for
all of us way more I mean look you might
not even be alive you could have ended
up being a bus a tree I just don't get
the mentality of being head down sad on
a Monday morning I'm Gonna Make You
Saturday Monday morning that's what I
want to do every morning and that's what
I want from you please take a step back
and think about how awesome it actually
is and then recognize that you can
attack the world in a totally different
way because you were lucky enough to be
born during this era [__] you Monday